[موسيقى]
العماره ليست مبنى ولا مجرد صوره تعجبنا
ونقع في غرامها العماره كائن حي عضوي
يستمد الجمال والعظمه والروح من الارث
الثقافي والتاريخي والديني للانسان انها
لغه مستقله بذاتها هكذا يرى الامر ضيف
حلقتنا الليله المهندس المعماري البارز
عبد الواحد الوكيل الرجل الذي رفض في
بدايه مسيرته المهنيه في مصر الانسياقه
وراء الطابع الغربي الذي طغى على مدارس
العماره في مصر والبلاد العربيه واصبحت
معه بلا روح ولا هويه ولا تاريخ لا شيء
يشبهنا كما يقول ولا قوانين تحكم العمل
والهندسه والتصميم بخلاف ما يؤمن به
الوكيل في العماره لا يوجد اراء واذواق ثم
قانون ناظم وحاكم لهذا العمل مثل كل
العوالم الاخرى ولا يجوز مخالفته اما
الذائقه فانها تعمل ضمن هذه الاطر
والضوابط التي تحكم هذا الفن في مسيرته
المعماريه التحم عبد الواحد الوكيل
بالعماره الاسلاميه تخصص كما ذكرنا في
الحلقه الماضيه بالمساجد فبنى اجملها في
المدينه المنوره وجده وصمم مركز اوكسفورد
للدراسات الاسلاميه في انجلترا وهو يؤمن
بضروره احياء القيم الاسلاميه وابداء
مظاهرها في العماره واستخدام مواد البناء
والتقنيات التي تحافظ على البيئه من جهه
وتعكس روح المجتمع والتزامه الديني
وثقافته وتاريخه من جهه اخرى اكثر ما
لفتني في تاريخ ومسيره الرجل انه كان على
خلاف ما نشا عليه خريجه فيكتوريا وابن
المدارس الانجليزيه المنغمسه في المنهج
الغربي يعود للجذور ويصر على وضع بصمته
المرتبطه بالتاريخ والموروث الاسلامي كان
الرجل يعامل الحجر على غير ما نعامله نحن
ويرى فيه ما لا نراه المعماري عبد الواحد
الوكيل المهندس البارز ضيف المقابله في
الجزء الثاني فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
انا اعرف ان عندك حساسيه من العماره
فاخذتك لمكان محايد الطبيعه كما هي في اي
سنه ولدت
كانت مزدهره دراسه الهندسه المعماريه في
تلك الفتره والله كانت عين شمس من احسن
كليات اخذت
الشرف اولى طلعت وعينوني طلعت الاول على
الدفعه في 65
الفكره
اللي انا يعني اختلفت فيها مع استاذي مش
في العماره بتاع لا من ناحيه السياسيه
انك انت لو عايز تبني للفلاح بالطينه
هيقول لك انا ازاي اجوز بنتي وانا عايش في
بيت طينه لما اخترت انك تروح مع حسن فتحي
ايش عملت
من الكليه من
كوكبوا عليا تاخذ العماره للفلسفه دائما
يعني هذا ما لاحظته من كثير
العماره كائن حي البنى ده هو اهم خلل
للانسان
[موسيقى]
اهم صوره تراها كيف ينظر المعماري للحياه
للكون
[موسيقى]
في
انا
من زهري احب كان عماره اليابان
لان عماره اليابان
فيها
موروث عجيب يعني
حتى في المعبد الايزو ده كل عشرين سنه
بيهدوه ويبدون تاني عشان الحرف كل جيل
ياخد خبره حريص على الحرف اه جدا في
الحلقه الماضيه انهينا الكلام عن الحرف
ولما جبت
الحرفيين من المغرب لبناء المسجد الاسلامي
في السعوديه وزير الثقافه صديق ابن عيسى
عبد الله بن عيسى كان خايف
واذا اندثرت ايش المشكله
السؤال استفزاز اريد الفكره واذا اندثرت
الحرفه ما المشكله فيها معناها غير مطلوبه
غير مطلوبه
الحرفه الباقيه هي الحرفه المطلوبه انت
عارف
بنينا في نيو مكسيكو فامريكا
اقتصادها عايش على الحرف
بيروحوا يشتروا انت النهارده لما تلاقي
قميص
معمول يدوي
باغلى من المكن لان المطلوب
الاتقان في اعلى
الروح الانسان
بتتجسد في اللي بيعمله من هذا الغرض
السؤال يا بشمهندس انه انت كمعماري مهتم
بالروح بالفلسفه
بالجوانب الانسانيه لا تتعامل معها كماده
يعني الانسان الاقتصادي ده مش مش كامل
الانسان اهم حاجه في قبل الاقتصاد وقبل اي
شيء روحانياته طيب هذا اللي عجبك في
اليابان بيهدوا المعبد كل 20 سنه مثلا
وبنقول الحرف دي انت لو تشوف البرنامج
بتاع التلفزيون عن اليابان تشوف انحرف
الاكل
الاواني كل شيء معمول
يعني
باتقان وجمال الجمال ده ما بيجيش كده
العماره اليابانيه يعني معجب فيها وبعدين
الموروث مهم جدا العلم اثبت دلوقتي ان
الذاكره بتقبل فيجينز بتاعه البني ادم
يعني
الجسم ده اهو له له ذاكره مش موجوده هنا
لها انت لها ذكاء يعني لما تتفرج على واحد
زي ارطور روبنشتاين بيلعب شوبان شوف ايديه
رايحه جايه استحاله ان هو بيكون
جينيا ايده نفسها خدت الذكاء ايش علاقه
العمران بالبيئه المحيطه فيها
كيف ما علاقه العماره بالبيئه هل يجب ان
يكون هناك علاقه بين العمران عمران بشكل
عام والبيئه البيئه مهمه جدا لان انت
النهارده لو جبت
متر مكعب اسمنت بيطلع
متر مكعب اكسيد الكربون
بيعمل تلوث
دلوقتي عشان يقللوا الاكسيد الكربون عن
مواد البناء المستخدم 10% المواد فبتسالني
يعني اهميه لان دلوقتي هي اكبر مشكله هي
البيئه
يعني البيئه دي لو باظت احنا مش هنعرف هل
يمكن ان نشهد ثوره في مساله مواد البناء
لانه الانسان كان عايش يبني قبل ما تظهر
المواد الحديثه
بشرح لك دلوقتي الاسمنت لان هو دايما لما
ادي محاضره بتاعتها يقولوا لي انت شغلك
حلو بس ليه انت مش عايش بالزمن بتاعك ليه
ما بتدبنيش بالاسمنت
يعني بروح
الزمن الحاضر ليش قلت له يمكن زمن الحاضر
بتاعنا ما لوش روح
لان لان مثلا في غابات في كندا وفي
استراليا اللي هي
مشاكل بيزرعوا فيها الخشب
لما تبني بيت بالخشب الخشب ده الشجره دي
سحبت اكسيد الكربون من الجو
الخشب اللي بتاخده التبني به بيتك
مخزن اكسيد كربون ما يوازي انت تقريبا
بتسوق سيارتك لسبع سنين
عكس الكونكريت عكس الاسمنت الاسمنت بيطلع
كربون
ما يوازي سياره بتسوقها عشر سنين او سبع
سنين
فانت بتدور على البيئه طيب بس سؤال هنا في
المواد لو كانت المواد التي تتحدث عنها
كفيله
ببناء هذه العماره الجديده لما استغنى
عنها الناس
لانه وقفنا عند الناحيه الاقتصاديه تذكرها
في الحلقه
الحداثه وبعدين
لازم تعرف ان الزمن بتاعنا الزمن
استغلال مادي
من وقت ما بدات ثوره اوروبا الرينيسونس
اللي بسموها النهضه
[موسيقى]
حصل تغيير في الفكر جامد جدا
فالفكر ده اثر في الفن واثر في العماره
واثر في الاقتصاد ازاي
حاجات كتيره اول شيء يعني من اكبر مشاكل
موجوده بالنسبه للبنى اللي هو الربا
ما حدش من المعمرين بيدرس موضوع الربا
الربا ده يعني
[موسيقى]
انا كان في مكتبي كان بيجوا يجتمعوا
البنك الاسلامي لان كان ليها صديق الله
يرحمه مات كان اسمه داود موسى
هو بدا الحزب الاسلامي في انجلترا وكان
بيجتمعوا فمن ضمن الحاجات اللي كانوا
مهتمين بها موضوع الربا انا مكنتش افهم
حكايه الربا دي تاثيرها ازاي
فمن ضمن الحاجات الربا
الغلو بتاع البنى دلوقتي مش جاي من غلو
المواد جاي من الربا
90% من البيوت اللي بتتبني بالمرجج قروض
الربويه
ابنوكرا 90%
بيستولوا عليها وفي امريكا نفس الشيء ليه
لان غلو البيت مش في المواد وبتاع قالوا
له البيت في الربا طيب هذه تكلفه اضافيه
اللي هي طريقه حصولك على التمويل بس انا
اقصد في مواد البناء نفسه اللي تقوله ده
بشمهندس هل هو عملي يعني هل نستطيع ان
نستغني عن الاسمنت والحديد والتسليح وتقل
تكلفه البناء عندنا الى الى 60 50
انا لما رحت انجلترا عشان اشتري بيت
فرحت اشوف العقاريه اشوف
لقيت بيت مثلا في ثلاث اربع اوض مثلا قول
ب100
الف والاقي بيت تاني اوضتين ب 150 الله
ليه وفي نفس المنطقه في انجلترا فلقيت ان
الفاليو بتاع البيت القيمه بتاعته هي
البيت اللي فيكتوريا
ليه مبني بالطوب
واسقفه عاليه هذا اغلى اغلى
قيمته اغلى لكن تكلفته انا ساكن في عماره
طيب تكلفته انا ساكن في عماره 1900 يعني
فات عليها 120 سنه اديني اي مبنى اسمنت
ايش 120 سنه طيب الحين احنا عندنا نقطتين
كل الكباري اللي عملها هتلر بتتهدد دلوقتي
لان عمر الاسمنت ما يزيدش عن خمسين سنه
طيب عندنا نقطتين بشمهندس عشان بس نكون مع
بعض يعني على نفس الموجه على قولتهم
تكلفه تكلفه البناء بعيدا عن المواد
الحديثه الاسمنت والتسليح اقل اقل انا
تحديت المقاولين كلهم شافوا شغلي لقوا
اجيب مقاولين اقول لهم تفتكر كامل المبنى
كلف
فكلهم ضربوا زياده 40% من التكلفه اللي
عملتها
انا ممكن اوفر من 25 ل 40% توفير بالمواد
زين وبالنسبه للوقت والجهد اطول الوقت
دائما اسرع المواد الاساسيه لان لو عايز
تعمل قبه اسمنت زي اللي عملتها انا عندك
لازم تبنيه بالخشب هيكلف وبعدين تعمل
الصبع الخشب وبعدين تجيب الحديد المهم من
غير ما نخش في التكنولوجيا لو بتبني
بالاسمنت في تسع
تسع مراحل عقبال ما تتم من التسليح ومن
الخلط الاسمنت وغيره بالنسبه للتوب هي
مرحلتين بس
وبعدين لو انت بتبني بالطوب وبتقفل كل
حاجه الاسهم في كله بالتوب في تكلفه تانيه
محدش بينتبه منها انت لما بتجيب النهارده
في السعوديه او هنا بتاع بتجيب حد يبني
مدني بتجيب عمال طيب لو جبت عمال عايز
تبني بالخرسانه وبعدين عايز تبني الحيطان
بالبلوك وعايز تبني فبتجيب كذا
جروب يعني ليه
لكن لو انت جيت
استخدمت خامه واحده تخلص بها البيت بتوفر
بتعطيني نفس الشكل الموجود حاليا الفلل في
الخليج مثلا البيوت البيوت اللي بيسكنوا
فيها الناس خلينا نضرب مثل على الخليج
المواد هذه تعطيني نفس الشكل اللي الشكل
البيوت الحاليه ولا شكل اخر تديك شكل احلى
من كده
وبعدين ما تنساش لما بتبني
بالتوب الحراري ده ولا التوب الفخاري ولا
بتاع زي زي زمان القله دي كان يحطوها على
الشباك وحطوا فيها ميه
فالميه تتبخر تقبل قله ساقعه
البيت المبني بالتوب زي اللي بيلبس قميص
بوليستر وبيلبس قميص قطن
بيتنفس يعني حتى في التكييف وفي
بروده 40% في التكييف ما فهمت سمعتها
بالحلقه الماضيه بس ما فهمتها بمعنى اللي
هو استخدم هذه المواد انا لا احتاج الى
100 طن احتاج الى اربعين طن الاسمنت انا
لما رحت اعمل ابحاث لما جم بنوا السد
العالي وغرقوا
الكره اللي في اسوان الجميله
الحكومه بنت لهم مباني
فرحت اصور الحاجات دي الاستاذ حسن فاتح
حر وبتاع قعدت مقبره سنه على
في جبانه
فقالي واحد قال لي انت عارف
المدفونين دول ايه قلت له قال لي ولادنا
من البيوت الجديده اللي عملوها لنا دي
فرحت السقف اللي عاملينه الكونكريت
الاسمنت قست الحراره عشره سنتي تحت السقف
90 درجه الولاد بيموتوا من الحرب لكن لو
تشوف الشغل النوبي زمان بالابوات الشمس ما
تضربش فيها بتيجي من ناحيه ومن الناحيه
التانيه ظل حتى
والبيت والتوب هم بيبنيوا التينه بس حتى
بالطوب المحروق زي انجلترا وزي في المدينه
بيعزل البيت عن الحراره طيب هذا بشمهندس
حتى في دول الخليج قبل النفط بيوت الطين
كانت الناس تعيش فيها بدون تكييف بدون شيء
كان في طريقه بالتهويه عجيبه غريبه هي لها
عيب واحد
اللي هو اللي هو لو جات لها ميه طينه
خطر
فدلوقتي في البولي ميرز اللي ما هي هنا
ميزه التكنولوجيا
اللي طلع دي خمسه في الميه تخلطها
ضد ضد المياه انا بنيت مسجد في
جنوب افريقيا
فقابلت واحد اسمه مائده الظاهر من اسبانيا
اسمه عربي المائده مائده
ده كان مهندس تينا
فكان بيستعمل البوليمير ده يرش على الطرق
الطينه عشان ايه لما تيجي الامطار ما
تسحبهاش يعمل لها
تثبيته
فاشتغلنا معاه ابتدى هو
بخبرته كعالم
[موسيقى]
تربه
اشتغلنا معي يعمل لنا طوب
بالماده دي خمسه في الميه والباقي كله
طينه
وبدل ما يعملوها بالضرب في زي ما كانوا
بيعملوا في مصر زمان عنده مكنه بتضغط
عشرين طن بدل ما يسيبها ست ايام في الشمس
على طول الضغط ده بيطلع منها
الميه وبتتماسك وبيشغلها
القالب بيعمل
فيها سنون كذا بحيث ان هو يركبهم بدون
مونه بتوفر
مرتين ونصف الوقت اللي هو كان موجود زمان
التكنولوجيا من وين نجيب الطينه هذه من
الارض نفسها يعني بكل بلد يعني
في السعوديه يقولوا انت فاكر نفسك هنا في
وادي النيل ما عندناش طينه في السعوديه
جبنا اثنين خبره من ايطاليا لان ايطاليا
احسن مصانع فيها توب
راحوا في المدينه
الجبل كل سنه بينزل الامطار في بحيره كده
كل سنه
بتنزل الامطار مع
الالوبيا بتاع الجبل والمجاري هذا
4 سم حطينا مصنع
الميمنه حطيناه على البحيره دي بقت بنينا
طوب خدت منه يجي 30
مليون طوبه بنيت بها كل المساجد
من المدينه وبعدين في الرياضيات فاطمه بس
عفوا يعني هذا في الحجاز لو قلنا في
الرياض في الكويت في قطر في البحرين في
الرياض حنلقى المواد
في
جده لقينا وادي فاطمه في الرياض الدرايه
كلها طينه
بنيت انا اشتغلت مع الامير سلطان بن سلمان
عملنا بيته بالطينه
فبالتالي هي موجوده موجوده اكثر حاجه
موجوده في العالم الحجر والجوده بقائها
اطول يعني يقول لك الخرسانه تقعد 100 سنه
100 سنه الطوب عندنا الروماني والفرعوني
3000 4000 سنه
ما شاء الله
وبتكلفه اقل يعني وابرد يعني تضحك زين بس
الاشكال انت عاوز تبني لنا بيوت زي البيوت
القديمه بيوت الطين ولا اشكال حديثه ايه
الاشكال للبيت الاشكال الموجوده اليوم ما
فيش الانسان
يقول لك هو
الاطار بتاعه المكعب
يعني
لما يعيش
انه مات كده في الطبيعه
زي السكيمو يبني بيته لانه هو منفرد ابن
مدور بس اول ما تبني مدينه لازم تعمل
التربيه
اي واحد بيعمل مبنى مدور دلوقتي يبقى مش
فاهم العماره لان اساسا انت لو عندك اوضه
مدوره تفرشها ازاي بحوض ومطبخ او بحمام
او بمكاتب ما تعرفش تفرش مدينه عربيه
تعجبك يا باشمهندس
تاسر كمعماري
انا انا عجبتني سمر كانت قوي شعرت انه
تصميم المدينه
عمران المدينه بشكل عام كل المدن القديمه
تركيا لبنان سوريا انا رحت في سوريا دخلنا
بيت قديم بالحوش تلاقي الولاد بيلعبوا وفي
السكينه في لان هو كلمه مسجن جايه منين
مسكن من السكينه من السكينه فانت انت انت
عشان تتعبد لازم السكينه
انت النهارده
التلوث
مش بس
الكربون الاوكسيد
العن تلوث النهارده في المدينه الضوضاء
اصوات مفيش السكينه الخليج حدث في تحول
كبير جدا سواء في الدوحه في دبي في الكويت
في الرياض جزئيا بحد بسيط المنامه كل مدن
الخليج اصبحت تعتمد نموذج الابراج والبناء
العالي انت انت تسال سؤال
تقول لي انت النهارده اي واحد هيعمل حاجه
لازم يفكر فيها يعمل شوق يفكر فيها
يفرسفها انت النهارده لما بتعمل المدينه
الجديده
على اي اسس يعني في واحد كاتب قال لما اجي
اعمل المدينه بيقول لابنه حاكم في قصه
واحد حاكم في الصحراء
فبيحكي اسمه سيتادال اللي هو دوزنا
مقدسانس سانت ده كان راجل شاعر عجيب
فبيقول القصه حاكم بيموت فجاب ابنه قال له
انا عايزك تحكم قال له بس لما تيجي تبني
المدينه الجديده ما تجيبش مهندسين الطرق
جيب الفلاسفه جيب الشعراء وقول لهم يوصفوا
لك الرؤيه للمدينه بتاعتهم جمالها
فيها شجر قد ايه فيها ظهور قد ايه
فيها
يعني قال له ما تجيبش مهندسين الطرق احنا
النهارده بياسس المدينه مهندس طرق
انا اشتغلت معهم
في المدينه
ما يهموش هو عايز يعمل طرق
بعدت عن سؤالي ايش رايك في المدينه
الخليجيه الحديثه
انا مش بتاع رايي انا واحد احكي لك حكايه
واحد هات الزبيبه في راسه مهندس في بيروت
من عيله كريمه متدينه جه قابلني على موضوع
المساجد
فجاء قال لي انا جددت في المسجد
انا قلت ايه التجديد يعني اعمل ايه في
التجديد قال لي المناره بدل ما اعملها زي
القديم خدت الهلال وكبرته
هو
الراس بتاعته عملت بها المناره كلها
فقلت له الهلال ده بيبقى يعني نهايه
المناره عملته من الارض ليه كده قال لي
تجديد قلت له انت ازاي اللي راح يفصل
بورنيطه زي دي فالراجل اداها له نزلت
لرجليه
ليه
التجديد ده لازم يكون فيه علم وراءه ليه
عملت كده
فقال لي احنا اختلفنا في الراي قلت له انا
عمري ما اختلفت معاك في الراي قال لي ازاي
انت مش موافق على التجديد قلت له لا بس
انا مش رايي انا بديك مبادئ
وقوانين البنى
ازاي تبني شكل انت لك رايي انا ما ليش راي
انا ما عنديش حاجه اسمها عبد الواحد
الوكيل انا
بستعمل العلم
وبستعمل المنطق
وبشتغل به
غابت القاهره الفاطميه وحلت الاعلانات
والبنايات الجديده محل العماره القديمه
وما عادت دمشق اما الخليج فتسقط مدنه في
التيه العظيم لم يعد الزائر للمدينه
العربيه قادرا على تمييز مدينه عن الاخرى
بسبب تفشي داء العماره الغربيه الحديثه
القائمه على نشر الابراج وغرسها برجا
يجاور برجه لا تكمل ازمه العماره والتخطيط
لمدينه العربيه في ضياع الهويه وغياب
الملامح وانعدام الروح فحسب بل ثمه ازمه
وظيفيه في غايه الخطوره تكمن في اضطراب
عمليه التخطيط الحضري للمدينه بدايه من
الاشكال المعتمده والوظائف الغائبه
للعماره وصولا الى حجم التلوث الناتج عن
استخدام كل ما توفره من مواد صناعيه حديثه
وما يترتب عليها من اضرار على حياه البشر
والمجتمعات امتها ثمه تلازم وتوامه بين
العماره وساكنيها كما يرى المعماريون وهذا
ما يخالف قاعده بناء المدينه وشوارعها
وابراجها ومنازلها على طراز مغاير لما
عليه المجتمع اذ تجري في المدينه العربيه
الجديده اكبر عمليه تغريب ونسخ عشوائي
للمدينه من اماكن اخرى مع مجتمعات وحاجات
وتفاعلات قد لا تكون ملائمه للمستهدف من
عمليه التخطيط والبناء هذه وليس ادل على
ذلك من المدينه الحديثه في الخليج فمن صمم
ومن طور ومن عمره كان من خارج رحم هذه
المجتمعات وكلما قام به نقل المعمار من
مكان لمكان قد لا يشبهه ولا يلائم طبيعته
وهنا يحتج المعماريون على مال ذلك من اثر
سيء على الانسان وحياته وطبيعته بل وعلى
الاقتصاد باكمله فضلا عن مخال فه ذلك كله
لقواعد البيئه والجغرافيه من الاساس وهو
ما يجعل من هذه المساله واحده من اكبر
التحديات لدى المدرسه في المعمار التي
ترفع صوتها في وجه هذا العبث لكن دون مجيب
لما تزور مدينه خليجيه حديثه تشعر انك
مدينه عربيه لا ما تشعر لا لانه هو مين
اللي بناها
يعني زي برج خليفه هذه من اللي بناها
في السعوديه لما كنت مصاحب واحد امريكاني
اسلم بيبنوا البرج بتاع التجاري ده هو
وبعدين عامل موجهه على قصر الملك الملك
زاهر قال لهم لا غيروه فوجهه على المدينه
فعملوه البيت
الحلو
الجداوي القديم بقى عامل زي
زي الماكيت قدام المبنى الطويل ده
يعني وبعدين ما فيهوش حيطه كلها
تشوف البنا القديم كل حاجه فيه حتى في في
العالم كله بس الان في هيمنه غربيه يعني
الطراز الغربي الحاجه هاي من على المدن
هونغ كونغ سنغافوره مع ليزيا حتى في تركيا
في اسطنبول اليوم كله الابراج في مدن
بتاعهم نشوف لان احنا بالعكس نتعلم من
اخطائهم دلوقتي هما عملوا اخطاء بيصلحوها
انا عارف مهندسين كتير في امريكا وبتاع
اسمها اسمهم
كلهم بيرجعوا للقديم مخططين الجدد
في اشتغلت معاه في ميامي اندرس ديواني
واحد تاني في كاليفورنيا وكلهم ودعامهم
الامير تشارلز وعملوا مدينه عملوا فيلم
عليها
ترومان
فيلم بتاع جيم كاري المهرج ده
فالمدينه عملوها بوكينج سيتي يعني ما فيش
سيارات فيه
رجعوا لقوا الاخطاء بتاعتهم احنا بنعيدها
ليه مش علاقتك بالامير تشارلز
الامير تشارلز عفوا
اصبح الملك امير كنت انا بكتب مقالات في
جورنال في المجلات
وهو كان بيكتب
مقالات او بيدي يعني محاضرات او بيدي يعني
خطب يعني
فقوم في مكتبي قالوا لي انت نفس الكلام
اللي بتقوله هو نفس كلام الامير شارلز
اتاري هو كمان عنده مستشارين مهندسين
وبتاع ابليس واحد اسمه
ورى له بيقول له ده
فقال انا عايز اقابل الراجل ده فلقيت في
مكتبي داخل واحد
من طرف الامين
في التمانينات دخلوا عليك المكتب قالوا
عاوز يشوفها قلت له عايز يشوفني في ايه
قال لي عايز يقابلك عزمني
في الاصل بتاعه في هاي جروب ورحت لقيت
مجموعه هناك
وكلهم بيتكلموا على العماره اللي يرجعوا
للعماره الكلاسيك
فانا مسلم الوحيد اللي موجود فيهم قلت لهم
ترجع للعماره الكلاسيك ليه غلط قال لي ليه
قلت له العماره كلاسيك دي عباره عن
بمعنى عشان بس
يعني زي وثنيه بتجن قبل قبل الاديان يعني
قبل المسيحيه
يعني جديد يعني
خدوا الجري وطنيه الجديده الكلاسيكيه جايه
ان خدوا الروماني وعدوه وشالوا العماره
المسيحيه
والقوطي الجوتيك
فقلت له انت هتبقى يعني
هتقبل رئيس الكنيسه
فازاي انت تقبل عماره وثنيه زي دي قال لي
اعمل ايه قلت له انت ترجع للعماره
المسيحيه المسيحيه
فصوته
ده الراجل المسلم اللي بيقول له ارجع
لعمار المسيحيه ليش
لان هي العماره مرتبطه بالدين
هم دلوقتي بقوا سيكلر دنيويه
[موسيقى]
الدين رايح عندهم انا كانوا يعيبوا عليه
يقولوا لي اذا انت عندك العلم ده ولسه
بتؤمن بالله
هم كلهم لازم تعرف تاريخ
النهضه جات ازاي طيب نيتش اللي يقول لك
ربنا مات طيب عشان منبع ايش قال تشارلز
لما لما قلت الكلام هذا انه انت حتبقى
رئيس الكنيسه ملك انجلترا
لان هو راجل عنده روحانيات
شمس مش بسيط
وبعدين بيهتم كان يقعد بالتلات ساعات
اديهم محاضرات وكان يعرف ان بادي محاضره
في اقصى فارد او في لندن يجي يحضرها
مهتم
هتموت مهندسين هاجموه هجوم جامد جدا
فاوقفت انا معك مستشار معه مستشار طلبك
تكون مستشار معه وبعدين في الاخر امر
اوكسفور سنتر للاسلاميكس
الاسلاميه
قال لهم قالوا له عايزينك تقبل بترولنا
قال لهم على شرط عبد الواحد يسمى مبنى انا
مش هقيد اسمي على المبادئ المسخره اللي
بتعملوها
وعملنا مبنى وخدنا شهاده من الملكه وعملوا
لي ونجح الحمد لله
كم استمريت مع تشارلز الملك تشارلز عشر
سنين مستشار في ايش بالضبط في العماره
او ثقافه يعني هو هو مش بس عماره راجل
مثقف جدا ويعني
بيهتم بالحرف وبعدين هو بس يعني انا بعدت
منه
كتف في مقاله في السعوديه لما راح زياره
هناك مصطفى امين عمل معاه مقابله
[موسيقى]
قال له ايه اللي حببك في العماره الاسلامي
قال له صديق لعبد الواحد الوكيل وحببني في
الاسلام
وكنت ادي له كتب عن الاسلام
فالمخابرات اللي حواليهم محطه كانت خايفه
عليه يعني
يدعم الاسلام يعني يؤذوه عنده علاقه خاصه
هو مع الاسلام
كان ياخد الكتب
المخابراتهم يسدوها وياخدوا اسم الكتاب
فانا حسيت ان هو لما يقول ان انا حببته في
الاسلام انه ممكن يضروني
لان هم في حرب
اه في مش مش من امير او الملك او بتاع لكن
من
من الدوله العميقه
فابتديت ابعد لان
يعني حسيت في
في غلاسه يعني المشروع الاساسي كان مركز
اوكسفورد للدراسات الاسلاميه في عملت
اشياء اخرى طلب انها من حاجات في لندن
يعني قال له ادابهم معي المهندسين
ديت اللي هي بيستثمروا العمارات في لندن
والارض بتاعته
فقالوا له انت جايب واحد مهندس
عربي مسلم ايش فهمه في العماره لندن
فقلت لهم انا بقى لي عاشق هنا
فوق الثلاثين سنه وجايين تقولوا لي ايش
فاهمني في العماره
الانجليزي وانتم من غير ما تروحوا بلادنا
بتاخدوا اكبر مشاريع ولا تفهموا في الدين
بتاعنا ولا تفهموا في المناخ بتاعنا ولا
تفهمه ولا عيشته في بلاد اسلاميه
قلت له الحمد لله احنا ما عندناش التعصب
بتاعكم ده ايش علاقه العماره بالدين يعني
اليوم نلاحظ بشمهندس انه بقت في بعض
الاشكال اسلاميه زي الشكل هذا مثلا
ايش علاقتها بالدين عملنا مؤتمر بتاع غخان
في
[موسيقى]
نيويوركس في المومه في مودرن
وجابوني في المحاضره دي
واحد امريكاني بيشتغل في
سكرتير في
يحبني
وعايزني اعمل له بيت في يعني حب شغلي
فكلمني قال لي خلي بالك هم جايبينك
يهاجموك
فخلي بالك
هيكسروك قدام الناس
فلما رحت رحت جرين روم عشان قلت لهم انا
عايز اتكلم اخر واحد
مديريه اللي هو مدير الحوار
اسمعنا اخر واحد قلت له عشان كل كلهم بعد
ما يتكلموا هطلعهم مش فاهمين حاجه ما انت
بقى عارف ان هيربوك قلت اضرب انا الضربه
الاولى اتضايقه بقى فاول ما قعدنا هاجموني
انتم
بكاشين انتم بتقولوا عماره اسلامي هي
الرياض فيها عماره اسلامي
وايه علاقه العماره بالدين اللي هو سؤالك
الجمهور بتاعي كلهم يهود هقول لهم ايه
وبعدين يعني جملتين فقلت لهم انتم انتم
بتقولوا ايه العلاقه بين العماره والدين
انتم لغيت النهارده لما تيجوا تعملوا حمام
وهتحطوا سيراميك تقول له تقول له عايز
موزاييك
في الحمام عايز موزاييك كلمه موزاييك جايه
منين
جايه من موزس
لما نزل من جبل بالتابلت
وكسرها وخدوها
لزقوها وحطوها على المعبد بقت هي
موزاييك له
اللي هو
فكلمه موسيقيك جايه اوه التسقيف بقى دي
عاطفيا طيب بس هذا ما يجيب على السؤال
علاقه العماره بالدين لا بس بس ما يجيب
اجابه كامله
لما اقول لك كلام زي ده وما تلقطش العمليه
دي معناها ان اي فن في تاريخ العالم
لا
ينمو غير عن طريق الدين
العماره الفن
الاسلام بتاع الاسلام
مئه سنه في ثلاث اجيال ضرب العالم في في
الجوده
الدين اثر فيها
كيف
انت اي حاجه بتعملها بتشتغلها بمبادئ
الانسان ما بيعيش من غير مبادئ
لازم يكون في مبادئ بقول لك ماتش كوره في
قوانين في ريفريت طب انت انت بتاسس ازاي
القوانين دي في في نظام للعب اي واحد
بيغلط او بياخد كارت او بيطلعوه
فانت نفس الشيء المهندس اللي يخضع ده يطلع
بره تتسحب رخصته
فانت ازاي بتاسس اي شيء
كل شيء بيتاسس
واحد مثلا وزير ثقافه بيقول لي
[موسيقى]
هو يعني
ما فيش اي رولز ما فيش اي قوانين المساله
قلت له ان انت وزير ثقافه تقول الكلام ده
قلت له اي شيء لازم يكون في
تحكيم
فاي شيء بيتعمل في قوانين جمال في قوانين
مبادئ
من غيرها تبقى فوضى متى بدات العماره
الاسلاميه يعني في اي مرحله لا يمكن ان
نصنف هذه العماره على انها عماره اسلاميه
اذا امار الاسلاميه
اخذت
زي القران
القران ما جددتش هو جه يصحح
فالعماره نفس الشيخ خدت
كل التاريخ للناس
الاسلام ما هو شيء ما هواش مركزيه او
نظريه جديده وبتاع لا
الاسلام بيرجع
للوصول طيب ايش ملامحها الاساسيه يعني اي
عماره اللي نقول عنها هذه تحديد الارابيسك
الاقواس الاشياء اللي نشوفها هذه ليش نقول
دائما هذه عماره اسلاميه امتى نقول هذه
عماره عماره اسلاميه
العماره الاسلاميه اللي فيها خشوع
ما هنا نيجي بقى دي حتى المشايخ ما يعرفوش
يفسروها يعني تيجي تقول ايه الفرق بين
الزخرف والزينه
تسال شيخ مثلا ما انا عملت مساجد والمشايخ
موجوده
ازاي مش متخصصه ده لو عملت رسمه
رسمه نسيج كده زي الكلين في السجاده يقول
لك بدا ما هنا تخش في الزينه والزخرف
الزينه تهيئ المكان
الزخرف ده تهيئ نفس البني ادم
ديكورم بيسموه
لكن الزينه دي ربنا بيقول لك خلق السماء
وزينه للانسان حيوانات اللي يركبوها وزينه
للانسان ما فيش ابدا في القران تلاقي اي
حاجه فيها وظيفيه غير فيها جمال معها لان
الله جميل يحب الجمال فدائما في جمال طيب
بشمهندس اذا اردنا الخير بتركبها لكن
الخيل فيها جمال انا كنت ارسم خيول اذا
اردنا تعليم العماره الاسلاميه هل ثمه
قواعد ثابته لهذا الامر طبعا خلنا نقول
ايش بيعلمها انا كنت هنا
يعني كان املي ان لما كنت رئيس قسم
العماره في قطر فاونديشن اللي هي
للدراسات الاسلاميه كان ان ابتدي موضوع زي
ده لكن لقيت هجوم من من بلدياتي
عايزين كل عايزين كله مودرن مودرن اه
عايزين موديل
وهم قايلين مدن بتاعهم ازاي
استفرجي اللي بياخد بدله سيدو القديمه
يلبسها مش فاهمه هو في العماره
انت لما تاخد تكنولوجي بتاخد الحضاره
يعني في في اخلاق
طب ايش الخطوط الفاصله بين العمار
الاسلاميه والعمار الحديثه
وظيفيه الاماره
الحديثه ما فيهاش الروحانيات
ما فيهاش وبعدين ما فيهاش ثوابت
ممكن واحد يعمل عماره مدوره واحد ممكن
يعمل عماره مايله واحد ممكن يعمل عماره
حامل ممكن ممكن تعمل اي شكل ممكن تعمل
عماره وبعدين اللي بيعمله مش مهندس دلوقتي
بيعملها الكمبيوتر ممكن تعمل
الكمبيوتر يروح معه يقول لك العماره
يعملها بالونه يعملها
فين الثوابت لو مكنتك في اي بلد عربي
كمعماري اليوم عربي مهتم بالعمار
الاسلاميه
ناقض للعماره الحديثه الحاليه ماذا تفعل
مكنتك وانت اليوم في الثمانين ما نحتاج كل
الامكانيات ماذا تفعل هامل
اسس المدينه الاسلاميه تلائم الدين بتاعنا
والحضاره بتاعتنا ازاي
ازاي اقسمها لك يعني دلوقتي ولا ايه
انتهت افكارها الاساسيه ايش افكارها كثير
اكثرها يعني انت بتقول لي اديني فلسفه
اديني مبادئ اديني بتاع مش مش حاجه مش
كارت هديه لك كارت فيزيتا دي دي عايزه
شورى وعايزه
تحليل
يعني
الناس بيفهموا مثلا زي واحد مثلا من
اصدقائي سي طه عبد الرحمن واحد
الشيخ بيفهم
طب لو قلت لك في حاجه لازم توقفها الان
حاجه بتتعمل ولازم يجب ايقافها زي ايش
ممكن ايش توقفوا وعندك القرار
نوقف البهلوانيات
انه مش كل واحد يعمل لي شكل عماره
انت شوف شوف فلاندا لما كان عمله لندن
ونجحت
سانت ريجن سبارك وغيره كل العمارات ماشيه
ستايل واحد جميله
ليه احنا
عندنا وبعدين الشارع مهم جدا
انت النهارده ما تقدرش تمشي في الشارع
روح في ايطاليا شوف الشارع كله
اركيد ومحلات هنا الشارع بتمشي فيه
وحواليك باركينج
احنا مدن بني ادم بنبيع للسيارات
مهندس عبد الواحد الوكيل انا شاكر ومقدم
جدا لك وسعه صدرك وجودك معنا في الحلقه
شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا حبيبي شكرا لكم على
طيب المتابعه القاكم ان شاء الله الاسبوع
المقبل مع حلقه جديده دمتم بخير وفي امان
الله
شكرا يا باشمهندس الف شكر
[موسيقى]